so a million questions first of all i
really hope you and the family and
everyone are healthy and happy during
this
you know um
uh i am curious you've had a great
career if someone had
you're you're looking at the side you're
like maybe
if someone has never seen anything that
you've done what do you want them to
watch first
[Laughter]
i don't know
that's terrifying
i don't know
uh
you know what i really liked um
uh
i mean
i
i really i mean i like barry obviously
um
um so that or or um movie i didn't call
skeletons
yeah
um uh when do you think you're actually
gonna make your feature directing debut
i would like to make it you know
soon you know i've written um
a couple of feature scripts and you know
trying to make that happen but yeah i
would love to that's that would love to
make a feature that's always been the
you know the goal so it's it's uh
yeah it's definitely something that i'm
definitely thinking about and working on
yeah i need you to do it just you know
yeah i mean if you watch barry barry i
mean the show is kind of like
hopefully
you can view the whole season as just
like one big movie you know and then
whenever it ends you can watch the whole
thing as just like one giant
movie you know i think it's just the way
my brain works you know
and uh
so
yeah
oh i i got plenty of questions but
jumping into adam's family one of the
things that i'm always surprised with
with adam's family even the animated
movies is how much dark stuff they get
away with in this pg-13 film the movie
opens with wednesday extracting brain
fluid from a character and everyone's
like yeah no problem
yeah well that's just the tone of the
show i mean it's kind of been that way
i mean just from the the charles adams
the
the
comic and then and then the show and
everything i mean it's kind of just what
the whole tone is that's really macabre
and uh
and that was what was kind of
interesting about seeing those reruns
when i was a kid of that show is getting
away with i mean just the idea of like a
disembodied hand
is a little creepy and like you know and
um
and that it was no big deal you know it
was kind of a new tone
you know um
that that adam's family introduced
when you uh you now have done so many
voices for animated movies and you're so
talented at doing voices what is it like
now when you walk in to like record for
adam's family do the directors sort of
just like whatever you want to do like
how what is that relationship now no i i
in a way it's because
i think
you know i've done so much it's kind of
like it's
at least in my experience it's it's kind
of like here's who the character is and
we're trying to be super specific of
like this guy was like a kind of like a
mad scientist type guy and so it's it's
just trying to be specific and he's uh
wednesday's a
mentor or whatever you know it's it's
kind of so it's
what would that person sound like and
trying to hit a very specific kind of
uh
movie archetype you know what i mean um
so that's always fun you know
when you're getting ready to play this
role how much before you arrive in the
booth are you finding that voice and how
you know what i mean like what is that
dynamic for you at this point looking
for a voice i i mean a lot of it is just
working with the director conrad i had
worked with before on a sausage party
and so it was kind of a thing of
showing up they show you drawings um
this one was actually done during the
pandemic
so it was all like this it was over zoom
and
i was
i recorded this all basically under my
comforter in my bedroom
so they gave me a kit
and i set it all up and then i'm holding
a comforter up over me to get a clean
recording in my bedroom
and then talking into a microphone and
reading the script off my phone
i've spoken to people who were recording
in their closets
yeah yeah yeah they go in your closet
and
and everything mine has like wooden
floors so i had to go in a room that had
carpet in it
as you may or may not know we're kind of
fans of barry at collider
yeah yeah
little bit um i have to ask you how has
it been going filming season three what
can you tease people about it
uh it's going really well i mean we have
a month left of shooting um
everybody's been great
and um
i don't know if i could tease really
anything because so much
stuff happens we had some people
come in and shoot stuff we've been in
the other seasons and
yesterday actually they came in and they
have this a bit kind of cameo part this
season
and um
i showed them a still from the first
episode
and they were shots
and they went whoa what and i was like
yeah
you know so
that was that was a fun reaction so i'm
gonna just see what people think about
it
um how many episodes are you directing
um let me ask you that
uh is it okay so it's an eight season uh
it's eight episodes for the season
yeah um
i know that uh you wrote you guys wrote
all of season four during the pandemic
how did the
writing of season four possibly impact
season three in terms of you're like oh
we need to tweak this to make this whole
yeah a hundred percent that's what
happened is we would we mapped out
season four and then
and then
went back and started laying stuff in
season three that could be in season
four and uh
it was really helpful it was kind of
like a great way of i mean we season
three we end up kind of fully
overhauling a lot of elements of it
because we've written four so
um
it was it was good
yeah uh i got to stop there i'm just
gonna say man you know how you know how
excited we are for barry and uh you know
i wish you nothing but the best and you
know seeing you man thank you guys for
all the the great uh
love for the show over at clyder it's a
thing that we yeah it's it's in the edit
room it's it's me and alec and aida
rogers our producer everybody will be
like you see what collider said so it's
always uh so thank you guys
yeah the best part though is i'm glad we
didn't uh jump on the bandwagon it like
once it got successful do you know what
i mean you guys were into it like from
the get-go so it was really nice
it's kind of good i gotta go they're
gonna kill me listen good luck with the
rest of the interviews talk soon
later